a couple of years ago you may have run
across a pretty popular YouTube video
that showed dozens of trucks
apparently carrying sewage out of Dubai
this video is in fact legitimate and
those trucks were indeed filled with
human waste but in a city as modern as
to buy why were they forced to truck out
poop from even the newest buildings
including the Burj Khalifa well to
understand this we have to first take a
look at how Dubai was built all of
Dubai's wonders are funded by the
government in an effort to draw tourists
and businesses into Dubai from around
the world and in order to attract new
immigrants they have very lenient tax
policies in fact they have no sales or
income tax they have slowly been able to
grow other streams of revenue to make up
for this but like every country they
have to take our debt whenever they want
to embark on a new project and this is
precisely what they did when building
the Burj Khalifa which cost 1.5 billion
dollars but this is not their only
expense they spend billions of dollars
expending Emirates fleet building hotels
advertising and building other tourist
attractions evidently they accumulated a
lot of debt and they still do have a lot
of debt in 2018 the biased government
debt was estimated to be 65 billion
dollars which is 56 percent of their GDP
now there are plenty of countries
including the US who have a much higher
debt to GDP ratio of over 100 percent
however the difference between these
places and Dubai is a source of stable
income as Dubai has no taxes and no oil
revenue they are dependent on tourism
fees and investments which are all
directly linked to how much interest
surrounds the city it all depends on how
many people are interested in visiting
the city how many people are interested
in living in the city and how many
people would use their services
consequently a 56% GDP decoration Dubai
is much more volatile than other
developed areas on top of this Dubai was
also affected by the global financial
crisis of 2008 causing many state banks
to nearly collapse Dubai actually had to
get twenty billion dollar bailout from
the central bank of Abu Dhabi in 2009 to
avoid bankruptcy
they needed to get more income very soon
or they were going to go bankrupt and as
Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum
the rule of Dubai has pledged not use
income tax as a way to pay off debt he
really wanted to avoid using taxes that
this was just further decrease Dubai's
credibility as a result the
concentration turned to finishing the
Burj Khalifa as this would draw a lot of
new attention to Dubai and increase
revenue and as they were rushing to
finish the building they decided that a
sewage system wasn't necessary as this
really wouldn't add much revenue now
it's not that the Burj Khalifa itself
doesn't have a sewage system as it does
it's rather that the city's sewer could
not support extra waste being added by
this giant building and as a result it
is not connected to city sewer and given
their critical financial situation
spending time and money on expanding the
sewage infrastructure was simply not a
priority and so they didn't on top of
this trucking out waste would be cheaper
than expanding the sewage system in the
short term but as the Burj Khalifa
opened and people started happening it a
lot more waste was produced and expected
the Burj Khalifa is capable
accommodating 35,000 people if all of
these people were all fed we would see
up to 7,000 kilograms of waste per day
and that's just the waste itself you
also have the water and toilets which
add to a total of about 15 tons of
sewage per day you can quickly see why
this is such a big issue evidently
trucks came throughout the day
constantly pumping out sewage from the
building but not only was a city's sewer
lines not capable of handling that much
waste but neither were the sewage
treatment facilities themselves which
caused trucks who wait in line to dump
human waste at the plants for hours at a
time and as the city continued to
rapidly expand this became the fate of
many buildings in the city center
despite this Dubai's main goal was still
expansion and worldwide recognition so
this issue wasn't really addressed for
many years especially because a tracking
system got the job done
Dubai did eventually start explaining
their sewage system as health and
sanitation concerns began to arise but
these were just small investments here
and there too
public concern it wasn't until 2017 that
dubia actually made a serious plan to
eliminate these orange tankers in 2017
they budgeted out 30 billion their homes
are about eight billion dollars to
vastly improve the sewage system the new
sewer design is based on some of the
most advanced sewage systems in the
world including Singapore furthermore
after completion the new system will
help reduce waste water generating
millions of cubic meters of irrigation
water but all of this is still just in
the beginning stages as construction was
just started in 2019 and not expected to
be completed till 2025 fortunately
though this system is expected last well
past 2050 and eliminated most if not all
orange tankers and Dubai will finally
have a sewage system that is on par with
its modern sleek City but if you happen
to visit Dubai anytime soon that is what
those orange trucks entail if you guys
thought that this video explained Dubai
switch problem well the measure drop
alike and consider subscribing invited
to see more questions just like this one
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari I'll see you guys on the next one